[موسيقى]
هذه الصوره توثق لحظه وصفت بالتاريخيه بين
زعيمي بلدين يتجاوران جغرافيا ويتخاصمان
تاريخيا لحظه توقيع اتفاقيه وقف اطلاق
النار في اقليم ناغورنو كارباك عام 2020
بعد مواجهات تانيه بين اذربيجان وارمينيا
مضت ثلاث سنوات على هذه الاتفاقيه وطوال
هذه المده تكررت كثيرا المواجهات الداميه
اخر فصول العنف كانت في يوليو تموز 2023
حيث قتل سبعه جنود من الجانبين في تجدد
لاطلاق النار وتقاذف البلدان الاتهامات
بالمسؤوليه عن هذا الخرق فما سر هذا
الصراع الذي لا يهدا وهل يستحيل تحقيق
السلام على هذه الارض
ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
الذي لا يقبل الخمول لابد من قراءه
تاريخيه سريعه تعود بنا قرنا الى الوراء
عام 1921 وفي ظل الحكم البولشي في تبنت
جوزف ستالين
السياسي وقرر الحاق اقليم كاراباك
الاغلبيه الارمنيه باذربيجان فاصبح مثل
جزيره محاطه بشعب مختلف بالدين واللغه
والثقافه ومع تراه للاتحاد السوفيتي قرر
المجلس التشريعي في كاراباك عام
1988 الانضمام الى ارمينيا في تحد للقانون
الدولي الذي يصنف الاقليم جزءا من
اذربيجان
انهار الاتحاد السوفيتي واعلن الاقليم
بدعم ارميني انفصاله عن اذربيجان
لتندلع حرب استمرت حتى عام
1994 وخلفت 30,000 قتيل وانتهت بسيطره
ارمينيا على الاقليم ومحيطه بما يشكل نحو
20% من الاراضي الاذربيجانيه
عام 2016 تفجر الصراع من جديد وخلال اربعه
ايام فقط سقط مئات القتلى ثم توقف النزاع
دون اي تغيير في الخريطه العسكريه [__]
مر الحذر بضع سنوات وفي السابع والعشرين
من سبتمبر ايلول 2020 اشتعل صراع اعاد رسم
التاريخ
[موسيقى]
دخلت اذربيجان الحرب دون حرج قانوني
مستنده الى القرارات الدوليه التي عجزت
المفاوضات عن تطبيقها وبدعم عسكري تركي
استعادت باكو الاقليم والمناطق التي
خسرتها قبل 30 عاما وتوقفت الحرب باتفاق
جديد اشعل غضبا شعبيا ارمينيا على الحكومه
عادت الارض الى اصحابها وفق الاعراف
الدوليه لكن الصداع الديموغرافيا اطل
براسه المهددا باشتعال حرب اخرى فبحسب
الروايه الارمينيه فان خمسه وتسعين بالمئه
من سكان كاراباك هم من الارمن القوميين
وهي ورقه كافيه للمطالبه بما تسميه يرثان
حق سكان الاقليم بتقرير مصيره وترد
اذربيجان بان المعطيات الديموغرافيه
مصطنعه وليست حقيقيه وتقول ان اسباب غلبه
الارمن هي عمليات التهجير التي اعقبت حرب
1994 يدخل على خط الصراع ثلاثه لاعبين
دوليين تركيا التي تدعم اذربيجان بحكم
الامتداد القومي وايران التي تدعم ارمينيا
وروسيا التي تمتلك علاقات قويه ما طرفي
الحرب هذه العوامل الى جانب معادلات اخرى
مثل حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا والصراعات
المحيطه تجعل من اقليم
جغرافيا ملغومه قابله للانفجار في اي لحظه
[موسيقى]